Kito is a we say granny Joe KEYT oh yes
sir well when you're in ketosis right it
means your bodies were not running off
fat probably the best way to lose weight
I don't know for sure they have a
bluetooth-enabled breath sensor did you
talk about hacks ketosis yeah the most
accurate consistent the first time ever
you see user-friendly bluetooths
breathalyzer an app for healthy low carb
and keto eating what's up bro eight
different levels of ketosis it nice and
then the need for you know you urine
strips her blood tests not makes it
easier just make speed aikido kid super
easy and it's accurate it's on point and
the keto breath sensor is just $99
provides keto level readings as well as
access the QIOs upcoming food products
within the app for only $8 a month users
can subscribe to keto premium for access
to videos articles recipes just a
heart-healthy gudo program restaurant
guides you take your skinny ass
somewhere and you're like what's keto
you're gonna find out now I'm skinny but
you're spread in city city you don't
breast sensors in Premium Subscription
are available at getkey TOCOM slash
fighter that's GE t ke YT o comm slash
fighters Aikido app is available for
both Android and iPhones just search in
the episode store for Aikido that's KEYT
o enter promo code fighter for 20% off
you know what I'm seeing a lot more of
did wrinkles on your face
yes but I'm also seeing a lot of dudes
at your bar yes but I'm also seeing a
lot more whoop o-tama okay more and more
people are wearing whooping are you
gonna go with this I'm always like oh is
that is that the other thing and they go
now now it's a whoop yeah it's a whoop
because they want to optimize their
training because it's a wrist worn heart
rate monitor that peers to your phone
dude you can see everything you're
getting you can see I looked out at
calories you're burning yeah you can see
how well you're recovering it's cool
whether they should take a day off yeah
whoo
recovery it looks at the heart rate it
looks at your resting heart rates sleep
quality it's the biggest thing for me
it's like sleep cycles sleep quality
there are times within each stage they
see you you see when you're getting REM
when you're getting deep when you're
getting light sleep it's crazy it is so
crazy dude all day these demos o through
the three point it's actually the most
most up-to-date technology you can get
yes it measures your recovery your
strain your sleep as when I mentioned
your strange full-day heart rate
monitoring with insights in the heart
rate average heart rate resting heart
rate max heart rate calories burn the
amount of exertion a user has throughout
the day in crazy weather I go on a hike
in the morning chasing like in the
afternoon maybe I went to a pumpkin
patch maybe a B maybe I'm just running
around the house but it calculates all
that to a tee it's so damn accurate and
then mine's your sleep so you know what
is up and who provides insights through
the app from the heart rate data
collected to help you make a better
habit of performing optimally okay Brian
at the end of the day that's all whirly
convinced right all right dude get the
woop 3.0 strapped right now you guys get
$30 off your purchase with the code
fighter all the silver October kids are
doing it talking about rogen Chrysler
Segura re they're all doing it there's
teams let's go to whoop calm that's wh
Oh Pete calm use the code fighter at
checkout to save $30 optimize the way
you train that's woop dot-com promo code
is fighter
hey ranks yeah yo Briggs what's up man
what's so rude listen they don't call me
rinks when I do stand-up they call me
the man dragon and if you guys want to
be turned to cinders
our brand the brave huh damn it I'll be
in Philly this Friday sorry not
pretending to be addressed Thursday
Friday Saturday Philadelphia Philly
helium tea pack a.com for tickets then
Thursday night next Thursday night
October 24th sha'ban friends at the Ice
House in Pasadena October 27th me and
shop are gonna be at the Comedy Store
with Sunday night that's right night for
charity Brian watch a dragon November
14th through 16th I'm in Dallas and at
the end of the month 21st to 23rd of
November I'm in Salt Lake City Utah
December scan City Atlantic City and
Oklahoma
get you tickets tea pack a calm just
sorry man sorry we were just talking
about kissing a guy yeah who makes us a
coffee and we were almost dead we're
kind of serious because he's got a great
mouth and beautiful hair well I don't
think he would appreciate you called him
a he to the transgender I don't know if
it that's true not true
oh you things just a dude that is super
feminine yeah I don't know again I don't
know cuz I get a heals all I said you
have nice hair oh he did yes you did oh
she or he I don't know what he wants me
I don't know his pronouns be it heals on
and then I always [ __ ] up with every
morning when I go over there when I
shoot I go what's up I stopped my me
Tyrion bro I I did too cuz I said oh
he's got a nice hair and I was like I
don't know if I should say he cuz he's
so feminine that I'm borderline
attract a little bit like I'm like what
a good-looking
Oh a pouty lips
howdy little hair and all coy and
coquettish all like hmm ride made a joke
of it bombed he lost man you have nice
here you said somebody or yeah and he or
she just goes just look coming I was
like yeah and then do you know split his
headphones on really thank you speaking
this wise up no fooling you talk about
conversations with strange yeah very
strange I'm gonna I'm gonna make a move
on and how do let's see what have I mad
at him he's my boyfriend girlfriend
other side well if you were spending
time with him let's say it's many time
with favorite row names her Sam now
let's just say her in because we don't
know so her in or him with is what is
the sir whatever the fight is serious
spend time with this person I think
after a while you would think of them
way more as a woman than you would a guy
right no I don't think so you peel back
that peach and there's a [ __ ] pair of
nuts hanging down below you I know but
the mouth and the no hair on the face
and the long hair pouty you know I mean
you'd be like oh man there it is she'd
be like what me like you I'm sorry that
this is I'm sitting in my car the gay
ring strikes again how they deal there's
a gay ring strikes again dude
you know they comin right you know call
me a common gay rings now you're working
at a coffee shop you probably need some
help with your rent I'm happy to do that
really both yeah I I hope you hear the
rent you wet my beak if you know what
I'm saying yeah that's having lunch
across the street I was watching these
some gay dude sat down at the bar next
to me yeah I know the guy with the
toupee the worst to pay for ever seen
your life oh my god is a very strange
thing it's doing very nice person he's
such a sign nice and such and
good-looking guy and like yeah I'm here
anyway yeah I'm I'm not searching thank
you very we're very where you think it's
a comb-over
I can't it's so figurin terrible yeah
there's no way you went to a wig store
and bought that yeah and then put it on
I was like yeah yeah a throw with this
you have any hairstyle yeah I I'm it's
one of the more incredible
things I've ever seen you should ask him
about it yeah you said you go look and I
go oh that's that's the most it might be
the most incredible thing I've ever
since the right insane hairpiece
virtually like yeah like I came out when
I shot in 3d wanted to avatar in 3d I
was like this is amazing and his hair is
same is the same it's hard right when
you see like oh hell yeah there is yeah
I'm always amazed that people do that it
was got to get picture of them right it
looks very Trump ish very Trump --is--
very trumpet oh dude I saw I saw the
Joker you did
so Joe you know what's funny to me is
saw the Joker your definite people like
you obviously we joke Bobby Lee in the
real enjoy O'Brian's it well no you're
definitely in it and you're in it with
scene with [ __ ] Joaquin Phoenix yeah
and the the main actors like you never
speaking role in it you know I um I went
so hard in the paint on my show
yesterday I would say man far superhero
movies in a complete realm of its own
best
that's not even best hands down the
performer for me and I know you know
acting for as far as acting the best
performance I get chills Lima the best
performance I've ever seen on screen
there you go heavy heavy and yes so
disturbing yeah so [ __ ] good ride
doing that oh dude I'm done Oh tried
doing that that's oh no that's right
mean when I saw that first opening scene
I went like this I told you I go oh it's
gonna win an Oscar
oh my god is all the hype like you you
tell you told me like you when you're on
set you're telling me about it yeah Todd
I've see the agent for the whole goddamn
thing was telling how good so all the
hype was there and you Riley I'm telling
me and then I saw the week late so I saw
all the responses with no great smile
tunnel yeah that's gonna be all right
I'm talking standing ovations dude
unbelievable like what the [ __ ] Todd
Phillips ladies and gentlemen get him on
the podcast Todd your head and what's
funny to me is ruin Gozo top fell
Tania's stay in his Lane just do cut are
you out your goddamn why are you talking
about definitely a town event as far
have to be a super hero fan
the movie you just that movie and stands
alone yeah
I've never seen anything like it so
disturbing so happy yeah when I read the
script I went I remember I came back to
set and I looked at I went wow there's a
party it was a big risk for him cuz he
thought he didn't know he did not know
if it was gonna go well superhero movies
are tough yeah cuz especially this the
audiences are so like rabid and like no
one ever it knocks out the park well
yeah that's perfect you get so much
criticism you know so yeah and he lost
by the way he lost legitimately seventy
pacify rocking Phoenix house he
literally was like girl I will get you a
nutrition he's like now I'll take care
of it I think was eating like an apple a
day and smoking cigarettes and there's a
scene where he's uh loosing this shoe
and it's just his back I was there
oh my god dude how about the small is a
small person legal remember what to
dinner with yes we went to how good is
Lee we're so Brian I was shooting the
[ __ ] Andy Cohen chill watch what
happens live yeah I had owned that Brian
was shooting Joker trying to say meet me
at this bar it's like right up the
street from where I'll shoot shooting so
I walk up that walk in brine I didn't
tell him that I'm not it was gonna be
you know I don't know an attractive girl
may not lucky in Phoenix
yeah beer boycott Philip you have not
Feldman I'm all excited I'm literally
I'm jogging over there yeah I walk in
there's uh there's a small person yep
and Lee can't stand one thing about Lee
is that it drives him crazy that
everybody treats him too well like he's
to have little person so we're on the
street and the [ __ ] guy his car
stopped and he's I got Jesus everybody
stops him everybody gives me a seat it
just gets exhausting because he could
never get away from it so I didn't say
[ __ ] to Brendan yeah he's seen in the
movie I don't split for anyone he has a
scene in the movie where it steals the
movie he's a great actor steals the
movie but and it's the most comical part
of the movie where you're I'm talking
have you seen a cat no he was just at
the Y I was just in the Comedy Store for
their premiere you was yeah and it was I
we hung out a little bit but I love
these great I love the guy I love him in
that black
good lord here's the other she's so
[ __ ] hot
here's the other thing though like
people online making fun of Brian I know
he's not here that much hold on hold on
they they mark it and I love Maron Manzo
he's been great to me at the store they
market they advertise mayor and being as
much as brian has they're about almost
the exact same really almost the exact
Mirren hat says one line and goes
something like go really and then just
shake his head when you know they're
gonna have with Robert De Niro but
they're yeah in about the same babies a
little more you know I never I never pay
attention to these kinds of things
no I don't my brothers tell me he's like
gee he's like God so stupid up Bieber
but todd todd is such a badass oh my but
do you love Todd Phillips yeah he is
their best
yeah one of us and it's great but Leigh
Leigh's Lee's s Dudley is never like
Lee's one of those guys you may be a
little person nevertheless he get in
this way dates nothing but regular gals
tall women and hot kills it there's a
dresses up look at them look I don't
know if I wear the hat fuzzums that's
mommy I like it
hmm feel like it adds to the you know
the Leprechaun vibe yeah right you know
he'd probably appreciate that in the
green suit do ya think very he's got a
sense of humor though he'll do all kinds
of well he was great man yeah he's a
hell of an actor I'm glad you like the
movie he listens to the show dude that
[ __ ] dude
there's scenes in their way it is just
so good yeah I can't wait I can't wait I
wasn't invited to the premiere man to
talk again that's weird because I mean I
wasn't I didn't see I don't know nobody
again that's weird cuz Amir's not in it
that mutt like if mayor there you should
be there yeah like he I don't know if
someone's calculated screen time but
yeah he might be in a minute longer than
you I love her
I don't care no I'm just saying it was
gone anyway it might have been in Tampa
I think that's a sure miss tamela to do
though it for the premiere yeah yeah
yeah the thing sucks though but yeah
premieres I've been doing enough
premieres yeah does nothing for me no I
just beat yeah I guess I can hang with
Todd but you know what keep looking good
yeah man he was a huge cat
you have to be strange to be that good
he's [ __ ] he's just such an actor you
know I told you that you know they were
trying to go for Leo and I'm my opinion
I don't know unless I woke up thinking
about this this morning who'd make a
great Joker Shia LaBeouf
I'm stat crazy yes any has the skills to
do it
where he'll go super deep into a roll
yeah he is that movie I forget what a
peanut butter Falcon you don't talk
about let me see in the trailer for this
know everyone I know who've seen it it's
off so you know I did I saw it yeah you
saw people Falcon I think so yeah it
looks good let's see it oh no you oh you
say oh I think so it's supposed to be on
[ __ ] I feel it plays a criminal right
who's no nope he's uh he basically takes
care of this kid who has Down syndrome
yeah they're like they're like a team
and he's into wrestling it's supposed to
be so ridiculously good
he's amazing too these guys are just
let's do what they live for just to be
actors you know just whatever it is to
like to embody this role completely
that's their thing not so much mine no I
asked you to play the tough you like
well I would try of course they actually
plays yes I bring my thing to it but you
had obviously everybody's afraid of
doing something like the Joker because
you're compared to all the other Joker's
so historically I know this isn't gonna
be but well I don't know what that'd be
like them more than I bet I knew you
would hold on I knew Johan Joaquin
Phoenix compared to Heath Ledger they're
not in the same ball I agree with you
there's an orange and I agree they're
not in the same realm Heath Ledger was a
it was a was a co-star and you only saw
me it was these crazy moments and it was
action and all that right no no you're
not dude I'm telling I love Heath Ledger
and he won't ask for it they're not in
the same you're talking WNBA to NBA yeah
I agree I'm dead I'm in this thing I
think you are current on the same lane
man what he did were they like whole
[ __ ] yeah man now you you are what came
fasted for that role
didn't now did he fast for months look
he fasted for I believe three months you
[ __ ] up am i when you see his body and
he's obviously has a horrible eating
disorder yeah
it looks good all your girls but the
[ __ ] were only doing it because you say
yes so obvious are being skinny I didn't
you want to be a bird I couldn't do it
a little physical I would die no you
could never do it here too big you pet
you fasted for 72 hours
well that was the plan I because I was I
was working out and then this jhaqo
video popped up right he's just like
being suggested and Jaya who I loved
shouted to Jocko and a video popped up
and he's talking about fasting he was
like someone asked him a question his
podcast he's talking about fasting yes
United sent me to our it's not a big
deal you know after first freaking few
hours I drink some water then you
realize how dependent on food and it
reset your system and he's like everyone
makes a big deal about it's not a big
deal I thought it's not a big deal I'm
gonna do that it's not a big deal at all
yeah that's [ __ ] easy I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it so I set a picture you
and Chris went look who just started
saying to our fat Chris she goes
mmm let's not do that let's [ __ ] eat
I lasted till about 8:00 p.m. that night
yeah big man yet hungry yeah go faint
eyes did well the problem is I'm running
around my kid all day how's the arm tis
yeah well if you're gonna fast you
should do a little lemon juice with some
honey you can't have funny can you do a
new cough papal syrup and well no no you
tell my sugars bro you can't do anything
you do coffee with a little cream nope
black coffee new black coffee
now some people just do serve two hours
fast with just water it's a handsome guy
there well like look at this look at the
show he'd be like if you if you're
making us like a [ __ ] if you're
making a comic book and you drew a
marine or are you guy going oh is that
yes nobody knows is that big and that
the metal gear solid guy what are you
doing that's [ __ ] you my pet snake
familiar solid
yeah he's years of war what are we doing
one of those guys your listeners
podcasting look at his face you're
listening to podcast no he just he's so
tough he's just so tough yeah everything
I know like the questions who I got what
are you talking about and just you're
like oh god always looks like he's in
just in a bad mood look at his eyes but
he's super friendly you know he's a
black belt in jujitsu as well right I'm
sure I'm sure
no look at him legit
like really good legit like yeah yeah I
have no doubt it's just an athlete I
like some guy goes hey man how hard was
they in the show they called me oh how
hard was but you know like that thing
you see everyone makes yes not that big
of a deal
he was you're cold you're wet really not
that big of a deal made little sleep
deprived he's like any we actually
bonding it's kind of fun you know the
real [ __ ] is when you get into the
actual war that's where it gets tough
yeah that's right and your psyche god
dangit otherwise he's made also his name
is Jocko I don't spy on the earth to do
sites slip people so sick and then ow
motivate people I know it's true having
Tim Kennedy man five six do they roll
together I mean they're both seals right
rail team Kenny's the Green Bay look
he's thicker than tip that's that's
weird
they're both yeah it's weird to be
thicker than Tim Tim as a kid
they're both so [ __ ] weird thick and
just like you know people know you know
it's tough with all them you know
stronger than both if you you know start
you know stronger than both of them
did you John look at me for saying I
want to stick a sec you know if you cut
Jacko's wrist it goes we're coming to
America and it sounds like Neil Diamond
yeah you know it's stronger than both
those guys not brendan job do you know
stronger than both my you gotta do this
to me man look at me cuz you walk around
like a little [ __ ] UI this but that
really bothers me [ __ ] I don't think
it's wrong her than both those guys and
ready heavier hold on I'm not done you
gotta sit in the cut for a sec you know
strong elbows they offer your freedom oh
I know I did I did no no I I love them
you know stronger than both those guys
and who can tap them out look at me
oh I don't know I want no part right
Jocko got my answer Brendan Schaub look
me in the eye you know you know can tap
both of them Bushido and who's stronger
than them Chrome Gracie
Brenda shop I don't know dude I dunno I
dunno I know you know this but you won't
say it I want no part and I do know you
won't say it I want no I can
drives me [ __ ] nuts when he's that
God guys so thick they're not like
they're gonna shoot look you know I know
I know Brennan I know you you can
deadlift seven hundred pounds right now
a lot of weight a lot of weight
hey your gorilla didn't you didn't you
Kerry I heard this thing from Lauren
land now didn't you carry on her pounds
in each hand for like five minutes and
beat all the Broncos I did yeah I did
again I didn't fight for your freedom
but you shut the [ __ ] up dude look you
through bars
no no they're awesome they're awesome
Kay's body right no peds yeah I think my
nose coffee either dear that yep I don't
look like that no but you can hey hey
over here he thought it 185 you can't
get down to 220 on your no hey we had a
father you money anybody give me my 20
not my $1.00 I give him I'm on
thousand-dollar get Timna that's great
dude I love Tancredi that's good my
Charter is that always a jock coat
whatever picture of jock with his shirt
off look he's a beast he's a pit bull
you're not as cut as those guys about
knowing no bite you stronger you
stronger I don't you're more of a
gorilla than both of them that's the
crazy thing huh ain't that the craziest
thing dude you know I'm just gonna
really hurt your feelings it's gonna
hurt your feeling to it dude you're
gonna hate when I say this do you see
chuckles funny let me know oh you're
sorry I said that out loud I'm sorry I
said that out loud it is weird that your
freedom dude no I know I appreciate that
but just stop now I'm supposed to dick
ride him you know I'd you know well you
get your dick brighter when it comes to
like sorry all right then yeah you
promise I'm a seal humpers they can you
see harbor seal humper where's your Co
we're seal they call him seal humpers
we're seal squeals oh we are we seal
well oh no they're called the frogmen so
a frog boys frog boys yeah we're just
they make sure when you get done hey
boys we're just they're tight with frog
boys cuz it's called the Frog man right
improves your whatever Green Berets
really we're the green bunny hey tell
that dude do not wear those shorts eyes
green that I know we like your training
with dudes
yeah hey get those shorts put clever
those up
yeah Giotto is a Dean Lister black belt
like saris gotcha it's got some serious
leg locks probably yeah he's gonna be a
problem for a lot of people yeah crazy
well I'm gonna start can't wait to get
huge right now those guys make you want
to get on TRT
yeah I'd like to I want my face again a
fatter though if you're like TRT is
gonna blow up now if you take any bar I
got some guys you can talk to you about
it
animals read you up all the CrossFitters
that's what they do all the girls don't
sniff like that you know like you know
yes and I know yeah my say to our fast
didn't last that long yeah I thought
joggle can do it I can do it sour
oh wait I'm not a [ __ ] Navy SEAL yeah
yeah but I am but you know what my base
promise I have no reason to do it that's
why I don't do it yeah I have no read
like there's not yeah I don't know yeah
that's when eight o'clock roll around I
was [ __ ] starving like what am i
doing yeah you gotta have a reason I
need a I need a goal I need a reason
yeah not that I need a strict reason to
do it
yeah right now I don't I'm not on beast
I'll say I want to look like [ __ ]
jock going Tim Kennedy what are you
wearing right now ARDS 50s like 54 yeah
easy - 55 - 5-4 easy oh yeah yeah don't
say easy like that yeah you were looking
thick the other day I liked your hair
long
oh my hair's long yeah any cute kid with
your with your hair long you cute you
look good girl yours up hey that's not
nice
first of all instead I want to come from
the set right now my hair's been
blacking a little bit and I got some
oils in it no I won't you apologize the
fans there's no show yesterday cuz your
stupid TV show yeah I was doing we I do
we had do reshoots cuz we've been
through a number of show running but now
well yes you till win
well wish you till December unless I got
a back pick up order of eleven more
episodes
of Goldberg yeah it's all good it's good
models old school look what it means I
don't get to the road I've also had that
where you mean now in Crimea [ __ ] no
it's all good I would never complain
yeah you're fine I'll do the road and
you know what I'm done yeah you're fine
yeah keep doing this and then you're
doing spots uiview you did a lot of
spots at La yes so you're good I'm doing
Maz Jobrani is a charity tonight at the
Laugh Factory no idea it might be just a
lot of Persians always great artists or
tonight it's usually a lot of Persian of
the play you doing out at two spots at
the store you do good main rumen belly
good for you all right that uh-oh dude
[ __ ] you guys at the Laugh Factory on
Friday night of Saturday night I forget
the Fahim his new bit I feel I I was
laughing so I was laughing like the
goddamn Joker how can how very I was
laughing so hard at to walk out of the
room really yeah except I'm so big and
it's like like jerky how's it go I'm
gonna I'm gonna go back and work the pit
you can't tell you about a thing who's
TJ Maxx and uber dude
he's funny man fames hilarious yeah
hilarious he has the potential to be a
big deal you know if he does he's seen
the right people um I don't think he
gives a [ __ ] no can I ask you a question
you probably break this down okay thank
you I don't know i crush it I don't know
we're going with it that's okay you're
measuring from your a-hole No
okay so go ahead what were you gonna say
I was gonna say this morning I woke up
at 4:00 a.m. like as my son you know God
decided to go let that happen sad ass up
happens to me so I got up yeah could use
just a stress thing right but I'm not
that stressed so I was up before you
know I went down this weird rabbit hole
i watch this documentary on nazis and
drugs god you know me [ __ ] heavy
drugs the nazis were on right oh man
yeah methamphetamine are they used to
yeah there's nothing that's how they
used it non-stop stop now it's what
still use that pilots will still use a
form of it even American that students
did yeah yeah but they were saying how
the Nazis you know Hitler would make
sure they are on it and but it's crazy
what they accomplished yeah like I see
everyone hates Nazis but when you look
at besides killing 69 people I ground
that they covered but because one
Americans in English would rest the
Nazis they went sleep their basic
crystal meth and just keep [ __ ] going
yeah here's the problem you got you need
sleep you may sleep eat sleep break down
so after about four or five days of no
sleep driving these goddamn tanks
through the winter yeah they're like
we're starting to see things so the the
dream world in reality gets a little
blurry yes so then they started like you
know make some mistakes then also what's
interesting is they're obviously they
did did terrible people but they're
saying a lot of it was because they were
so you know high all the time like they
didn't look at like killing people the
same way the rest of the world like
their morals because they're so [ __ ]
high and like sleep-deprived some of the
[ __ ] they did they probably never do
well there was also there was also an
ideology I mean one of the things that
Himmler was famous for was who was the
head of the SS the SS was was
essentially the elite troops that did a
lot of the killing of the Jews and and
and cleared out what was called they
went through Russia and decided that
these Russia was just too populated in
the countryside and they needed Hitler
said we need this land which is fertile
for our people when we moved them in and
so the Nazis systematically came through
countless Russian villages
and [ __ ] killed everyone man women
and child they made them dig their own
graves and you can see pictures of where
they line them up and the women would be
holding their babies and they just shoot
them into the pit and they did it over
and over and at one point the young men
were trembling they just did then I'm
used to this they're like what are we
doing Himmler is famous for getting I'm
saying look this is for a greater good
and we're doing this for our mission and
so there was an ideology fed to these
men you're you're getting rid of really
a mongrel race anyway what's interesting
too is a Hitler like they they their
whole thing was like you don't put
anything in the body that's not healthy
for it so is he he's a vegetarian
vegetarian so they thought meat was bad
no I'll call you know they weren't doing
that but he was to them no drugs but
they didn't think of the time meth was
drugs he was on so much [ __ ] all the
time so much [ __ ] well get a doctor
though they this one's document he had
his own doctor that would go around with
him and this doctor you know Hitler
thought he was like the end-all be-all
he need him to feel good so he'd bring
him everywhere so this doctor use all
these pictures he's always by his side
always pumped him full all this [ __ ] and
then this doctor because he got so like
in crane in the in the [ __ ] Nazi
lifestyle one day he should you know
people made fun because he wasn't a
soldier he showed up in his own uniform
that he made himself
hmm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
dude great [ __ ] that's him right there
Theodore Morel say a nice guy huh
austere people God crazy fanatical
devotion to Authority very disciplined
of course Germany was also home to
Goethe and a lot of the greatest
philosophers like Hegel and Kant I mean
also some of the great great scientist
philosopher and literary figures moved
all over yeah yeah yeah sorry Nancy yeah
yeah interesting
wait great cars now let's switch gears
for a second let's drop the Nazi Tom
yeah it's just crazy on all those drugs
yeah um you probably broke this down but
I want to get your take did way real
quick before you begin the fight talk
yeah do you think like what are the Navy
SEALs to
they're definite you don't you know I'm
saying like Beyonc life and death if I'm
sure there's supplements maybe it's
adderall their site is provisional the
highest level yeah you don't save in all
sports at the highest Olympics baseball
football at the highest level
those guys they're taking stuff to focus
and make sure the mission gets done I do
know that I've talked about in certain
guys who say that you know when your
tires and money they'll take provigil
you take all those things you take
whatever you whatever speed derivatives
amphetamine salts whatever nothing said
I mean whatever it is I'm you know the
pilots do that too when they fly sorties
they have to stay awake so they take
provigil and different things like that
what do you want you to take if you're
Navy SEAL if you're a green brain like
you're wouldn't you take testosterone
I'm sure a lot of them do so you for
recovery like I don't see any legal but
then when you're a certain age you can
like if you you if your levels or drug
tests in that military right 4p here was
as there was a steroid ring that was
actually busted in Iraq or Afghanistan
among Special Forces guys from what I
read a while back but yeah you're not
really necessarily allowed to be taking
it unless you get medical clearance for
it you know
but I would imagine a lot of guys
probably need a little help for recovery
model fitting I've taken myself to go
pill pilots take it I enjoy it myself
oh and I mean night Eagle what the [ __ ]
isn't I'm not taking anything it's
called night Eagle I am poor sleep knows
I take all kinds of stuff cuz you're
working at night your clocks all [ __ ]
up you gotta figure though like you know
I'm saying like yeah I'd want my seals
like jacked yeah you want to be
functional but I you know you don't want
to be stiff but yeah I would assume
they're there on some sort of recovery
like TRT yeah but a lot of these guys I
won't you be a lot of this seals are
young too though they already young high
testosterone guys you know that's a good
point the Train yeah you know they're
just they're you know they they they use
it when guys get ahead injuries because
head injury apparently a lot of brain
injury what their social
yeah cuz it Fox here pituitary yes so
what you think though like you yeah if
they're been with so much battles
maybe there's brain trauma but also
testosterone you know it puts you in a
good mood gives you energy so maybe with
PTSD yeah maybe I don't know you know
what I was told
talked to my buddy and there's a lot
about this and I said I don't know if I
don't know what my testosterone is well
he goes do you wake up with a hard-on
I go no not a lot of time that's the
problem right and I guess he says then
your testosterone as well we all she
glares checked out yeah let's go I need
an excuse again I'd be down to do it if
you've got me to shred city lose weight
I felt my face getting fatter I know we
can go to some there are some good
doctors yes I need a doctor come the
house and like changed my you know you
owe me you don't want to go there now
just come enjoy your lipid panel now do
that you know the blood draw make it
easier for me dude I know send me kit in
the mail head size increase now that's
just like when you're holding water no
HGH that make your head grow but it's
also that this area gotta talk about all
the time your your masseter muscles
because there's muscles right here and
then what people take take a lot
yeah then this goes I'm just talking
about like raise my tester yeah you know
Rumble Johnson he's come back to UFC
when he's being a bot he it's already
out he came out last week but you know
he started being a bodybuilding with Oh
were you on a bunch in you oh yeah he
was if you didn't do it you have to do
it yeah how do you feel crazy cuz when I
was lifting I did but when I was in the
gym him steel I didn't feel great he was
trying to be a bodybuilder you up to 290
I think he said to 90 to 80 and what was
the decision to come back uh he watched
deep favorites DC was a guy can beat
these guys it inspires really yeah so
maybe he wants to come back and win a
title wow this is I wouldn't mind seeing
you guys just see him fight John Jones
with the way he hits yeah well that's
what he wants to I wouldn't mind seeing
him brush Francis in Ghana oh boy holy
[ __ ] that'd be crazy
locked on black crime yeah and he's a
better wrestler than ghana by far he
doesn't wrestle though yeah see look how
big his face is there well you know I
spent some time his face is so [ __ ]
wide anyway is his bone structures huge
what did you um
it's heavy there yeah well you 284 him
hello sir crease to fight at 117 and he
when I when he was fighting 170 we were
shooting warrior he was walking around
at 235 and I was like how are you gonna
do this he goes I'll get down crazy
right yeah just a [ __ ] house why he
left for something that was supposed to
be special right no he said he said
so he's fight supposed to fight John
Johnny that pulling out DC took the
fight and he said even when he's going
through cabbies like God I'm just I've
lost love for the game okay he's in the
back basically similar to situation he
told coaches I don't feel like doing
this man like wait I go out there he
goes so you see me in the fight kind of
looking for way out
ended up fighting in a way out was a
calm down it was this what DC yeah he's
only had two losses you know they are DC
in DC so only oh yeah DC twice so at
light heavyweight so you're tired as
number one Bob sees the contender lost
wonder what happens now hold is he 36
but at heavyweight you fine so we'll see
heavyweight you're fine that you don't
yeah heavy we're always older came
retired you know that came retired he
said yeah how crazy it then no one gets
it like it's not anyway like can you ask
is bounced with my top three great yeah
of all time but it was not you so long
ago people's you know people I'm moving
on the part of the province he hasn't
been active yeah so it's like especially
this new wave of ESPN fans they don't
know who he is right you know that's got
a [ __ ] up by Francis Lee yeah yeah
kind of I know it's Cain Velasquez I
know I know
well the greatest ever do it there's
argument here more fate or ever do worse
or Steve where's Weidman why he fights
this Friday he does at light heavyweight
who's he uh da McCrae is great fight who
Friday in Boston TD Garden great fight
phenomenal fight odd were you surprised
by the Cub Swanson fight no I called it
I died Todd put a thousands of dollars
on it you did yeah you call it oh yeah
terrible matchup for code I don't know
what the [ __ ] EST was thinking but just
because you know because was so [ __ ]
good he just he's just such an Emmy
all chrome does is graph that's we give
him Cub Swanson who's a black ball why
would they do that to him I don't
because they thought Cub lost his last
four so I go he's over the hill let's
give Cronin name like oh it's still Cub
Swanson he [ __ ] all comers yeah I kept
Swanson's had the greatest comeback
because Cronin after crooned in when
that fight in any facet it crossed the
board not even close
chrome gets the backstage because I won
that fight contact guys I definitely won
that fight and they have tweeted out I
won that fight and also the world is
round my friend because he's a flat
earther you and I won the I won the
fight in the world as definitely didn't
say I won that fight did he I heard the
same thing too I hate you how was what
was he thinking just delusional you know
like maybe he'll be needs to watch the
film you know sometimes you think you
clearly won a fight and you look like
like oh [ __ ] I didn't you know there's
certain things I don't maybe huh I mean
he thinks because he's walking forward
getting lit up like yazd aggressor i won
the fight nice getting lit up though
he's very new to MMA MIT if I wasn't
close cuz when he was bang his chest I
thought you're not saying you won here
are you
yeah and they like lifts them up like
what is happening right now
strange very very weird that's a that's
yeah was that the fight question you had
though yeah it was stupidest Michele
Watterson's fight Your Honor yunjin Jake
how dare you yeah I missed that
yes that's the main event I'm sorry she
got lit up Michelle did lit up she had
once you had a few moments where it was
she got her back but your honor looked
phenomenal
she got lid on you're honest so far look
there's chrome I won that fight he
posted it crazy dude
what crazy that's incredible to me I
love chrome I love girl and that I don't
know that's crazy okay yeah in that you
know strange man fighter fighter you
know when it's almost like you know it's
it's like you know playing the Patriots
you lose by 40 Mike I think that was
close to the neat thing we won that like
fighters were doing
No yeah the judge is ringman I'm judges
suck doing the just like what yeah we're
awful but even we didn't have that way
that's really interesting yeah there's a
lot a lot of good fights coming up man
yeah but your boy widening fights Friday
ah I like Weidman as a dog man I'm you
know me when Luke was going to
light-heavyweight I was super high in
Lucca light-heavyweight I thought he was
the answer for Jon Jones honesty didn't
work out that way
lack of itch was like hold my beer I
must suck in the [ __ ] jaw yeah and
Luke was slow or did he just didn't want
to be there there who called said it I
told daddy he's like I'm done I he said
after he won you what I said what I tell
what I tell you between that but you
said I throw it I'm telling you Luke
doesn't want to do it anymore
yeah in people like y'all you such a
hater like I'm hugging you in there I
was that guy I'm telling you I see
similar traits yeah looks amazing father
I was even close as talented see is Luke
and Luke you know no way champion the
world he's a Hall of Famer phenom UFC
Hall of Famer yeah Strikeforce Hall of
Fame yeah
what's the greatest ever do it I'm
telling you man yeah I saw something I
go oh no it oh no no yeah I'm telling
him it yeah mmm just how long can you
fight before you lose but there's you
look at certain traits and guys like
you'll get a guy who's in the thick of
it like a style bender yeah or like
Darren tail when he's you know like a
yeah oh you're Tony Ferguson you look at
these guys you are foaming
I can't wait to get in get in there
that's what it takes yes so when you
don't see that I'm gonna be a model over
here you know my leg did there's guys
who can't live without this man yes
those are the guys who make it to the
top of a tree now Luke used to be like
that yeah and then you said it here's
the thing there's nothing wrong with it
cane retiring fantastic yeah found
another career yes so 4ww here so
fortune I don't kind of pays getting but
I assume it's good cuz I think all I
think I don't want much WWE both Luke
and there's three major wrestling
leagues they all offered him contracts
so I'm assuming he's getting paid
Luke and Dale will tell you that that in
Cannes prime there was no one like
like he would turn their heads around
like him came on beat the [ __ ] did have
they told you stories about ya know beat
the [ __ ] out of everybody yeah own okay
was uh I mean uh and they Todd Duffee
was up there - during Kings right out
the hast motto one the best that I've
seen in the gym I was like okay no no
different thing right well yeah yeah
never and also had crazy cardio being
this there's the number one thing name
one guy and you have seen him go five
rounds at heavyweight right eating crazy
he decided do it see pay do it but not
like Kane where it's a tidal wave where
first round I can right second round
third round steep a applies oppression
as a similar kind of fighting style but
Cain that fourth and fifth was like a
Diaz brother you know I'm saying it's so
crazy head in your chest News nine back
bang kit low kicks punching great boxing
his great head movement didn't get for
fights and then you see and then was
fighting like Nogueira chit-chat Congo
Ben Rothwell yeah just a Brock Lesnar
who'd Keller and Romero I find the same
card when he fought up Brock Lesnar I
fight Gabriel Gonzaga opened up the main
card I thought Gonzaga
he fought Brock Lesnar how are those
what were those lightweight warrior how
are those leg kicks against Gonzaga yeah
I could've walked through the airport is
that true
uh-uh that day I was in a wheelchair
what oh yeah really yeah where was he
kicking you in the [ __ ] just like
ever he'd of hit and would you just
brace yourself you wouldn't check him I
would check him in out counter and make
him pay every time that was the best
I've ever heard like when you check
though I mean with your shin or you just
check no because he's doing all bone so
I just take it knock it in but I'm
trying to knock them out uh-oh I'll
trade you this for this yeah yeah keep
doing it I remember he's so hairy I
remember we were taking piss tests
together and I looked over at his piss
and it was brown what yeah it was like
baby's just super dehydrate it was like
upper look at that of course he pisses
Brown
it was brownish guy God he was so
[ __ ] scary oh yeah we're gonna soup
deep dive on fighting but remember
walking because k was fightin Brock I
remember I well that's what I want it
that's that's where I need to get yeah
I remember I was fighting Gabriel he was
coming off his loss against JDS then
they give him to me
and you still ranked that thing in the
top ten and I remember walking out going
if I don't beat him I'm gonna retire
really yep told all my team that I go if
I can't if I can't be Gabriel then I'm
just you know it I'll never be able to
get to where I need to go okay guys
three round decision man yeah you
haven't fallen is that you didn't you
just boxing him right yeah non-stop okay
hey click on that one where he's down
chin the far left yeah that's one yeah
those on that right was it does it yeah
like that one
where was this now if you a kick and I
hit him and he went down and was at the
end the rounder that was in the fight
end of the round
crazy right I don't recognize I always
think of you I don't reckon in those
situations is being like you just it was
almost like desperation like you were
like I gotta be a fighter I guess now
yeah yep there we go gotta just fight
out of that yeah all right I don't
recognize that guy he looks like knows
different Eric wold my nose took many
hits yeah terrifying just yeah but you
did a lot of like you were just throwing
you would throw in the beginning without
that one was all died just behind my jab
that does best man but as they call it I
was in the zone right that's great good
good yeah I was in the zone you know
when they talk about being like the
white light you're on the zone that's
the only fight I ever had my careers in
the zone ever just not nervous just kind
of just uh it's just there that day for
a reason
know what you can do look at that over
the top it doesn't feel good to block
that with your hand
well yeah here he is though he's
fighting a void talk about differences I
will be in Philadelphia at the
Philadelphia helium
he's fighting bare knuckle against
Bigfoot Silvan Florida that's a tough
one
is that right yeah that's right
be I'll be in let the Brea improv not
this weekend but the following weekend
two weeks October 25 26 get your text
and then October 27th at the Comedy
Store Bryan Callen France tickets are on
sale I'm there at yeah me shop it's a
Sunday yeah we got some big names
surprise guests combine yeah man um
you're going you're going to Philly this
weekend I leave Thursday morning yeah I
love Philly I'll go to some famous place
than making pizza what's their famous
beat the place that I don't know I don't
know they set it up and we will make
their Geno's is the cheesecake you're
gonna be in Salt Lake soon yeah Jan
Stevenson who is a I think that's where
you gonna be let me see what about him
he's got a distillery and with whiskey
and stuff she's at Hall of Fame by a
golfer a woman I'm sorry what's that
have to do with me what's that what do
you want me to do I mean if you like
whiskey she's got a distillery oh yeah I
love whiskey yeah
she'll bring you that that'd be cool um
yeah Jay set it up let me see no no did
I race it oh [ __ ] what happened I think
oh man here's a list no I forget
yeah private Orin tasting of her
distillery at in Salt Lake City so if
you like your whiskey and rum just got
everything oh yeah whiskey for sure I
forget the name of it but I'm [ __ ]
making my own pizza you're making like
over here Brent's fat ass is looking for
pizza
one of the top pizza places that one to
come in and make pizza have you eaten
that Felix yet
Felix every time not out here I'll
average Kenny is that our boys place no
dude you don't understand Felix the Cat
pasta and the kind of crust to the kind
of bread I get in a row you gotta break
it for Felix I I you can't get in I'll
get us in yeah and get his in good man
you're not walking heaven what are you
gonna do call for me Fresa
it's off Abbott yeah you're not get
you're not getting man
we're the best pasta nice hey know what
that's like yeah coffee in the world
look at me listen you go there listen
call me hey hey and call me I'm stealing
it no you're not good you're not gonna
call you Sal call my boy Matthew and
I'll get you in wouldn't you go dude
pull a little a couple of strings yeah
what kind of town go I go a lot I walk
in yeah well they they they get the
semolina flour from Italy the guys
trained in Italy and France and we're
about on it so obviously good it
defecate oh it's so good you'll lose
your [ __ ] mind
because you love that bread you'll lose
your mind I got real [ __ ]
uuugh I'm gonna say it out loud give me
my fave what's the best pizza in the
world
oh hi Julianne Jillian oh for sure yeah
Julianne take away to be specific the
large slice phenomenal the best ready
for this
watch your [ __ ] tone dude I will suck
you and your old wrinkly dip and I've
eaten I will have ego will sock you in
your grave I know let's dig I've had
some crazy pasta I've had some crazy
pizza what a great whiskey name great
when it comes to carbs when it comes to
pasta and pizza watch your tone less
sack in your old dick I got feelings
Felix over Jillian to take away the
large slices you'll see better than
Joe's in New York you've lost yourself
you'll see dude you'll see is it the
producer two small pies oh yeah mm-hmm
I mean it's like six sizing leave me
and we'll I'll try that on Katja I can't
wait oh it's a thick bread I'm getting
hungry now
Oh my mouth is watering my stomach I
almost got I want to take you there
tonight I get two spots dude yeah I know
it's so stupid sounds nice yeah it's a
beautiful thing yeah
you good boy sorry whoops looks I just
popped out yeah you Italian fans that
not really right every now and then ya
know when I create a pasta like I am
ravenous if it's a nice pasta you'll
lose your mind I gotta take you guys
Felix well we could do it for this rate
is like some carries a holiday dinner
didn't we do that last year yeah what to
scope it last year yeah yeah we should
do it this year what are you doing for
Christmas you'll be here of course up
here media wouldn't my gone in New York
for Christmas but oh no way got to do
that my crib he's a trattoria there it
is Felix Los Angeles yeah
so it's tough to tell him pictures right
yeah doesn't look the greatest dad right
this is so ridiculous
tough matter of fact hey Felix don't
post pictures your food it doesn't help
no but so good that looks if I was feet
so I'll just have hot chicks with fat
tits eating pasta like this hot but
putting hot chicks with fat tits
eating pizza right now we didn't do that
girl who he's fine chase with fat tits
eating yeah I know exactly you're
talking she might not want to eat flamin
hot cheetos you seen the fat girl
explain rocky toes yeah did she die I
don't know cuz she's not around any I
never see her anymore don't follow her
but I don't know
pasta burn fat hot chicks with fat tits
eating pasta let's see what car yeah I
was on YouTube though you can find
Carl's juniors their old stuff used to
be just hot girls with big tits eating
burgers that was cool yeah that's cool
and then this one me to move it starts
they don't do it anymore
alright thanks good they've never slang
somebody goddamn burgers the big Western
whoa see that's what I'm doing yeah yeah
yeah oh girl spill that tiramisu all of
your teeth whoops oh man what's this hey
oh here's a sausage God oh here's
Italian song and you're being immature
Brennan I'm just saying that's the
market I would do yeah everyone go to it
mm-hmm
you said hot chicks all the time
with fat tits I want you to think
Hooters meets Fazoli's if fat tits
doesn't really work when you say fat
tits Peter but do you think it look at
that [ __ ] you're talking fat aren't
they
no see here's the different new me I'm
talking pH eighty fat oh yeah
fat see I don't like that's disgusting I
don't like that I don't like that at all
hey see if that chick eating the flamin
hot cheetos still alive cuz I got a
negative real suspicion she passed away
what yeah clogged arteries back-to-back
come on money on it you know what to her
yeah we used to look her up yeah yes
yeah not like cool thick you know itís
probably model now the waist the size
probably how do we know if she's Wendy's
eating show 2013 look at that five
million views dude you sure hey guys
this is my new 9 weeks ago there are
70,000 subscribers more subscribers than
you break out that's lazy
I just put refried beans and that was
October 1st she's not dead no we get her
to go still doing the damn thing what an
exhausting job though and she just eats
just eats things with flaming hot
cheetos it's just a behind-the-scenes
look at her life oh don't see behind the
scenes let me see it eat something real
quick holy [ __ ] does she think of those
onion rings look at her too though dude
leave a set look at is it hold up is
that flamin hot cheeto uh kool-aid yeah
yeah me and she has a job doing this
[Music]
a bunch of fish right they always want
to buy the fish but come on
where at least look at them what is
happening now does she always eat just
flamin hot cheetos yeah variations I
should put them on doughnuts I should
put them in burgers or that's amazing
they comment it'd be nice to her well
she's making Bank you think yeah
907 one thousand subscribers you had
enough I'm buying that look at me of you
she has that's him that's remarkable
Oh flamin hot cheetos won't know me
grilled yummy salad Nutella and bananas
she deeply how's this end for somebody
else you know I'm saying yeah yeah you
were a honey boo boo
see now she's doing no no she just got
caught I think with yeah Krystal
Matheson why the little girl no the
little girl got caught no I think some
look it up yeah she might passed away I
just said about everybody yeah I know
she might have if I don't hear from I
assume they passed away honey boo boo in
the news yeah um Hampton mama June sells
Hampton home big loss maybe the mom now
yeah I can't be the comma June we both
not guilty to crack cocaine possession
no I'm tell you honey boo boo did
something but there's no young though
should I be in poor know what no like 16
or something hours I'm telling he she
did she got in trouble
wait why'd you put honey boo boo real
name so I can get her actual nah that's
not gonna make any headlines no knows
her real name let's see
honey boo boo proud to have been through
hell and back this year no pretending to
be oh yeah oh no she did cocaine on
Instagram that's right she pretended it
was cocaine oh but no no no no she got
caught doing cocaine I was like no no
it's just kool-aid and your big ass take
cocaine off see free cocaine you're not
skinny what are you doing hold this she
this little girl she's young man she's
like 16 or 17 or younger huh no hmm all
right well not alter itself all my
energy leaves my body when I start
hearing about people like this I'm just
saying that's how everyone's moving and
so it got 14 he's a child move why does
it say oh she's born 2005 you know I
watched I watched a documentary
Woodstock and one of the things I know
it's fun yeah one of the things I
noticed was that was 1969 and one of
things I noticed was literally literally
if 101 is that no it's fat rugs a lot of
drugs but literally back then no there
was no obesity profit American there's
none what happened processed food yeah
processed food that's sugar sure sure
sure sure processed food Oh sugar I
guess and then also like the the food
administration and their their agendas
and yeah the food the pot remember the
pie charts at every school had mmm carbs
number one and here that sugars and
breads some people just ate sensibly
there wasn't there's all in propaganda
like it was all a push towards yeah
there wasn't a whole lot of yeah but
here we get Woodstock yeah you're right
it everyone was a [ __ ] B everyone was
a [ __ ] everybody was a father little
pre-aids post pill you just took off
[ __ ] if you got syphilis you just
took an injection there's nothing like
Woodstock is there no God man that was
when times were they well work that
their parents had been in World War two
it was so fresh memory Vietnam was
raging drugs with the drugs were
Jonathan music was still a draft music
was popping yeah get people were
fighting for the independence their
freedom kids wanted a voice yeah then
the music was doing it I mean in action
rock and roll was new drugs yet Rolling
Stones popping you got Jimi Hendrix
Rolling Stones Janis Joplin Mamas and
Papas you got you got a rocket arrest
the hippie culture was starting to form
and hate ass rock and roll around what's
funny you know that Beatles were going
so say so you remember about this The
Beatles they heard about the hippie
movement going on Haight Ashbury
they flew over there got out of their
tour bus
looked around experienced for a little
bit this is no movement that's just
bunch of young kids on drugs yeah that's
the thing insane
I got back on the pointing and bounce I
bet there's also the time when
psychedelics were big oof that's living
brother never done them but that
mushrooms LSD the doors Jim Morrison my
goddess
Charlie Manson what a band The Doors
well here here is boyo those song here
no no no one here gets out alive
no I'd like to go ahead and play that no
one hears my voice listen a his boy
we're down by this house stayed in
Venice wrote a bunch of songs no well
I'll show it to you sometime
Charles Manson also stayed in Venice
Beach real long though back to our man
listen a.m. scream back to our man back
to our man yeah but you can fight you
can play you can spare no one here gets
out alive either just listen to his
voice know what dude if you don't want
to do heroin and listen to Raider riders
on the storm yeah and get your dick side
and play what are you doing is it called
five to one no one here five to one
okay that's I meant the yummy nuts he
was busted watch this too good-looking
dude okay come on only 300,000 views and
playing the organ
thanks wanna do drugs Oh was I thought
no that's the blues did hope you look
older now they look older
nope you look older nope you don't look
that gaunt man we got a nama how old
were you win this drop be 22 I was - you
were 22
probably - 22 years mom had put on up
man you have Woodstock I should know
Woodstock when the the
Rolling Stones were playing and they had
Hells Angels protect them they stabbed a
bunch yeah I thought I saw you all you
saw it in person the same screaming you
can take it off just listen ice do you
have any is any live footage of them
because the conspiracy is this was all
you know mmm it was just a Renaissance
man I hear you I got comedy right I know
it's a Renaissance yeah I hear you every
try out do each other and I know but is
it do you have any physical video of him
singing like this because the word on
the street is when people saw him live
they [ __ ] hated it uh-huh man shut up
I know I hate to ruin your mother
watches at doors I know dude the doors
were the doors well he was also getting
really high
you see his performances when they pull
him offstage because he was having a
[ __ ] break down Kurt Cobain so high
just lays down well the cops could the
cops took him offstage they just like
literally arrested him on stage jim
morris [ __ ] rock and rolled yeah I
mean he was it he was going he there any
physical video of him singing yeah Jim
Morrison yeah oh [ __ ] yeah here put it
and put it on watch him watch him sing
him when he gets arrested see as it does
yeah and that's why here no not even
that one there
the door he's ablaze yeah there's one
about raising where he's just kidding
when he gets arrested good-looking dude
you dress really cool too yeah what
turtlenecks all the time see much I grow
my hair like that you think [ __ ] yeah
dude would that be cool he's already
he's high as [ __ ] yeah you don't think
yes dick suck black state oh my god he's
high what a voice he can sing yeah that
conspiracy books full of [ __ ] I read it
seems that stuff yeah of course you can
guys we use a lure canyon boy though
their songs Marina del Rey I think
Laurel Canyon and then Venice Venice
yeah but there's a hill right you know
where he gets arrested on stage watch
what he's telling that the doors are
just him Jim Morrison dead the doors
yeah he's singing and get Morrison
getting a rest on stage I like Chin's
enthusiasm have you hating on him check
out we just can't show this stuff so
we're just like but the people can write
their own especially the music we can't
came in here
okay don't go now this would be the last
one
King Kong kind of lack and white
animation I know it's not the video it's
a better much better video let's see
he's high hmm
this one Brent don't I don't know went
down around don't don't see New Haven
was the only place to get arrested
that's all they got this was high as
[ __ ] leave his face oh boys here was
super long right on stage did he just
oh dear with it suicide uh he OD didn't
get there good good all did it 27 so
[ __ ] weird he's a child
how old was Mac Miller when he passed
away holy [ __ ] that videos creepy that's
creepy
Mac Miller was held now here's was OD
cuz they 26th [ __ ] man I was 27
poor kid 27 year old curse Avicii 28 ish
[ __ ] terrible men they've arrested
like yeah like they've arrest like seven
people died in Studio City man
what what happened he died from four
thousand all I told you guys it's like
you know thirty years old took xanax
they mix it with fentanyl he [ __ ]
died he had everything to live with he
just died yeah this fentanyl [ __ ] is no
joke cocaine they're mixing it with
cocaine sometimes be careful man be
[ __ ] careful
Jesus crazy man there goes my blow game
here it's no joke be some curtain little
peep Avicii but though they didn't IV
Chi Takashi hindsight I know our deal
from jail yeah so they said Wow how was
he and how long is he doing I don't
think they're gonna demo set some yet
right he still he's supposed to barely
do any time and get out cuz he snitched
on so many people it's so crazy he's
like no I don't need security I'll just
hire my own team it's like there's no
way he last long out in the streets
there's no way no he was going to I
witness protection
he should be passed on it he refused to
do witness protection
well he's uh
so excited to a ten million dollar deal
here's my what would you do be here
there they go hey man hey man listen I
know you're a per pretend to be a
gangster got in with the gangsters and
salt some real gangster [ __ ] unless you
snitch on your going to prison for life
what do you wanna do you snitch right
are you like that now I'm down for my
set dog yeah I'm gonna stay in here and
go to jail forever
I mean I'm squeal I'm talking my god I'm
school that's why I'm not a criminal
I mean less is gonna keep my son out of
jail or someone different thing I'm just
saying it's solely you
hey this these gangsters that he barely
knew he's trying to pretend he's a
gangster you bring me and go hey man
it's either them or you I'm yeah he's
going to jail though for a while huh
Wow well he was going to he's not
anymore they say he's gonna get like
three years or some [ __ ] now maybe
Saturday in jail that's not good cuz
he's still snitched
well it'll be and protective custody in
jail but when he in president but when
he gets down the streets he also you
know they're like we'll put you in
witness protection we can just go away
but you got rainbow colored hair and
teeth you get those tattoos off your
face
they said they probably won't know until
Sept 9 September January 2020 out Sammy
Sosa my face is he super talented nope
no talented of marketing you count that
mark in his he only is yeah it's damn
after testifying against that Bloods mmm
they put like two of the like
chain-of-command Bloods in prison for
life so you don't think they have some
family and friends and gang members who
want to get ahold of them who will also
go to prison for life just to get a hold
of him but he basically signed a death
sentence but also like if you hear like
real rappers who are who are associated
with gangs like these these young kids
want to pretend they're in it and he you
have no reason to be in it you know and
like baby then you start living that
life like if you're gonna be a gangster
like look these guys don't want to do it
they came from that yeah let me see his
picture here's what's interesting though
is so he got involved with that gang
right and the the
also gave him protection there in his
music videos they pushed his music
videos so it's like you made a deal with
the devil damn what the [ __ ] he's just
as strange that the tattoos are
hilarious what the [ __ ] is going on bro
crazy tattoos his girls a dime piece
though yeah she had tattoo of his face I
think on her face
what yeah they're all normal you know
look at that time here's what's crazy he
almost went to prison for raping a 15
year old girl - what a year's girl sweet
tattoo on your tits well he may not want
to have his face on your body either
she's very sexy you wouldn't you gotta
figure they're gonna go after her right
like he has a kid - which is the scary
part
oh good he's breathing huh cool okay
she's a baddie though sure disappointing
with those tattoos I also get off his
dick is that is that the mother of his
child
nope it was another girl right oh really
aren't surprising hmm
it's good some current events where you
got such awesome good choices
well better way to girls good choices
all the way around listen they did I
shaved my nuts today what did you Nick
yourself up a little bit dude yeah I
nuts look like Freddy Krueger nah it's
all marked up you guys all band-aids on
me I'm not safe dude you need manscape
dude if you're gonna if you're gonna
take I did that I nicked a nickel wrong
a little bit hurt it was a problem I am
stinging right now
thanks enough things you want to keep
things at least skate dates for nothing
but keep in shape
send me one dude same on Lauren 2.0 has
proprieties proprietary skin-safe
technology so this trimmer won't make
her snag him nuts man listen you know
more accidents and we've all had them
okay
yeah you wouldn't go near your face with
something what's up dude don't go dance
Klaus shave a design in your nutsack mix
up for your girl they got a crop
preserver - they got an anti chafing
ball deal
you already put deodorant on your
armpits why are you not putting
deodorant on your nuts nuts that a core
that sit right next to here how do
you're not right next here you're not
our fish nut
what's your mud whistle you notice then
get 20% off free shipping with the code
fighter at manscaped calm all right stop
being disgusting and I'll nicked up
manscape calm always use the right tools
for the job your balls and your shaft
well thank you and you went off and your
girl and the people you send dick pics
do use the code fighter manscape calm
20% off you know what I'm wearing you
know I wear I wear shyness t underwear
now you know shyness TR their underwear
they made of Modell
okay there's love the soft durable they
hug so what get this get this when I do
the school's my show and I'm wearing
shorts yeah right Schwartz yeah I need
underwear that snug to my body fits snug
I can't have things you know throwing
off my life there's other underwear so
value I wear my shyness T and they're
hilarious
I got like oh yeah one has have you show
me was like I'm the crotch bar it's got
corn dog hot dog funny all kinds of
different pictures cool hammock support
space just supportive ball hammock gives
the balls the space and security and
they need telling you right now it's 20
times softer than cotton - yeah so I'm
you know I'm sick of my underwear not
being funny
hey I mean real baggy hey okay yep balls
enhancing - people go dude what's going
on you gotta you look like you've got a
major balls and I'm like that's how I'm
built
cuz I'm better than you but if you want
to look like me even though you're not
me get yourself some shyness T's okay
wow man they they it is really great
they're really great though yeah
subscription if you subscribe now you
it's 30 you save 35% you get free
shipping on every pair there's no
commitments cause or five cans oh you
got it right there you go you can choose
any assortment of and frequency then
make sure you always have a fresh pair
for your pair and they want some NFL
teams on these maybe want a hot
Christmas suits seamless songs I don't
know you want a beer pouch retro ski
suits they got a bunch of stuff it's
hilarious yes
hilarious shyness tea is letting you
guys get your first pair of subscription
ball hammocks for only 5 bucks
just head to shyness tea coms last
fighter to try your first pair today
that's shyness t-shi n est why.com slash
fighter get your first pair of ball
hammock boxers only $5 your balls well
thank you
already here we are so a video was
posted do you guys know what tick tock
is the app ok is it kind of like
boomerang
it's like vine and musically in one app
I didn't what musically musically was a
where a lot of people went on they would
play music and like did low dance videos
like this so tick-tock is basically the
new vine a girl went on who worked at
Panera at the time and she posted a
video of how they make their mac and
cheese and a lot of people were
disgusted because they didn't know that
the mac and cheese came in this frozen
prepackaged bag and they would basically
put in boiling water to warm up they cut
the bag open put it in a bowl and serve
it oh and so she posted that on to
tik-tok thinking it was harmless she
didn't say anything bad about it she
just said this is how we make our mac
and cheese a lot of people were
disgusted and she ended up getting fired
from Panera Bread that's hilarious
Wow is all how dare you tell anybody but
at the same time I do naira Pratt I see
it yeah I thought paneros classroom it's
mad funny that was sub guy commentate
yeah did she probably deleted hers in
yeah she had to take you down she said
that her manager asked her not to talk
about it because the video went so viral
so for a couple days she didn't say and
they lost my job for this video that's
so funny that's he's disgusting but it
looks disgusting in that bag
yeah the sous chef is Panera Bread what
did you expect or
you told me about melting the cheese in
the back and making fresh noodle okay
it's not Felix yeah but also you go you
pay for him yeah it's like it's Panera
it's pretty good the breads good good
sandwiches yeah if you get an apple
you're not bad I don't mind
nice salad could smell cookies what else
yet so a woman in Tennessee was arrested
for disorderly conduct when a video of
her twerking in her car during traffic
went viral video [ __ ] you let's say a
held up traffic she said she was stuck
in traffic for like half an hour and
what ended up happening was she asked
her friend to drive the car while she
jumped on and just started dancing to
put on a show for everyone waiting in
traffic
she is 23 years old she little too good
at salad good I want to be mad that
would be super entertaining yeah on the
405 flexible they happen to you on the
405 [ __ ] I would love it slow enough
to yeah I'd love that
you're a [ __ ] she's just being a
silly goose I love it that she's good at
it it seems pretty hot damn they gave me
a ticket though they actually ended up
arresting her and then she made bail
Jesus guys know she can't really be on
top of a roof but I think it's awesome
so NFL player Deandra DeAngelo Williams
paid for over 500 mammograms what the
[ __ ] a mammogram that you would
basically do for women to make sure you
don't have any lumps in your press Oh
gotcha
breast cancer runs in his family his mom
and a lot of his aunt passed away from
it so he made he makes it a point to
play with his hair dyed pink in the
games and then he donates a lot to
several found he's retiring right I
believe he's uh I don't know if he's
retired he was that he was at Comedy
Store one night been very few people
were there in the original room and I
can't remember who it was but somebody
said come on up here and let's see who
can dance with their shirt off and he
was kind of pulled on he didn't really
kind of want to go I he wasn't a pro
football player yet he had just been
drafted and I'll never forget he took
his shirt off and he was dancing and I
remember
be in the back and I went like this I go
I go I'm I got it get in better shape
man look a guy he's got a very good body
I'm her saying I go I was like I got a
anymore I got everything where I said it
because in my mind I was like I gotta
get closer to that and then I talked to
him and he was with his sister I think
or someone and he said he said yeah I
just gotta go with you and half lady cuz
yeah just got drafted to the Titans I
think yeah and we were talking for a
while such a nice guy but I was like oh
oh you're a phenomenal is that when I
saw a state come on Berkeley and I go
guys got big legs you go oh you don't
know who that is you [ __ ] idiot yeah
what's going on with Nicki Minaj and
Tracy jamming it failed to reach a
settlement what the [ __ ] copyright what
song against Nick Minaj baby can I hold
you for the track sorry can I hold you
tonight you guys have the LeBron stuff
secured of it I do something but you
guys know way more about it than I'm
sure I do
but I have it up there alright what you
doing fighting trash should be condemned
[ __ ] this one funk you mean us yeah
alright you guys only just jump sit down
right now sure let me find what do you
think should happen with China well I
think China is one of the great very
egregious violator of human rights I
think that they are essentially a
Marxist staying here you make a lot of
money and you yet their economies good
but they're they what they're doing to
yours there are dear minorities they
just do whatever they want or well they
are an heir and with Hong Kong they had
a that deal with so skill to 2047 yeah
must be semi-autonomous but to 2040 the
Chinese will kill you the Chinese will
make severe they if you don't believe in
it they're gonna you didn't make you
despair the government here's what they
want tears what's so interesting about
this is LeBron forever with justice and
we deserve you know make sure it be
we're more than players and Kaepernick
you want take a knee and all this stuff
and then as soon as it affects your
bottom line because he's egos a scam
because and then I'm gonna hold up Nikes
hockey and you know the Chinese are
responsible 30% of the revenue and the
NBA's right so here's bottom line now
and so you hear what he said and I'm a
little ardent fan oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
when you could've waited to tweet this a
week later do you know the inconvenience
you've caused for me my team it's like
holy [ __ ] you [ __ ] that was na yeah I
saw it and I was like wow a rear my team
for a badass purr and makes a lot of
mistakes but my team in this league just
went through a difficult week one song
univers are in coastal areas yeah you
talk about the protesters and people are
getting killed and put away in prison
for life because they're a tough sytem
of speech yet oh I'm sorry to
inconvenience you and the team oh I'm so
sorry nobody stopped and considered what
would happen could have waited a week to
send it Wow Oh Oh turns out some
horrible fuck-ups this is numeral yeah I
saw him again I'm like LeBron James
Asajj sweat oh dude yeah no you gotta
brush up on your geopolitics got a chip
brush up on what China actually does the
government well do you know do you know
who this guy's Cantor no go down to him
so he's he's a variance he's from Turkey
it's from Turkey this is not what he's
responding immediately after he saw the
LeBron stuff but you know scroll up
Casey he right here's what this is so
this is what James tell reporters the
Rockets general manager daryl morey
wasn't educated on Hong Kong should have
kept his mouth shut as the spokesman
Lakers forward forward waited into a
charged debate that other high-profile
NBA figures have shied away from now
skis keep scrolling down look cuz you
see what Kanter put and it's he's had
some real issues he can't play this on
country yeah so he started doing all
these haven't seen or talked to my
family in five years jailed my dad my
siblings can't find jobs revoked my
passport international arrest warrant my
family can't leave the country God get
death threats every day got attacked
harassed
tried to kidnap me in Indonesia freedom
is not free so here's why camera says
that because Canada has been target of
the Turkish regime because of his permit
criticism of the Aragon's tutorial
tendencies and daddy that's right so he
has a unique perspective on the value of
the very freedom LeBron James appeared
to overlook in his defense of child
crazy and the same
thing happens to Chinese citizens who
stand up to the government and and they
just disappear in many cases how crazy
that's crazy it's like these athletes
you know and they're like Oh freedom
speech and we're more than athletes and
then suit the old tyrant being the
entire me as soon as it might affect
your bottom dollar they're all just like
no listen that's not our fight over
there and nobody hey man be cool it's
like oh you let's go man [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you giant put your money where your
mouth we don't LeBrons overall game plan
is right this is to get consume so much
money when you're tired wants to own a
team and be a billionaire we can't do
that without the finances of China
there's so many interests have you seen
how many look at ESPN how they're just
mute on this I watch it get up i watch
first take every more than I need
Spencer I get my talents anything huh oh
there's oh no they can't there's nothing
because too much money at stake I've
seen all the company including barbara
Lee all the company associated with I
know about the China nothing we're just
cool everyone's cool with it
everyone's cool with it yeah how [ __ ]
up is it money what's your bottom dollar
just yeah yeah yeah but there's people
being in prison and they're [ __ ]
these these innocent people over mitt
that's right how easy is it it's crazy
it's where you see who you really are
does it cost you something it should
cost you something freedom is not free
he's right does it cost you something
it's it's just Aragon in Turkey is a
dictator he did he did arrest countless
people you know and it's it's and until
you've suffered from it I've seen you've
seen it there you go
but even it but the NBA came out and
apologized for that GM of the Rockets
Wow like well we he has his own opinions
wouldn't agree with that we stay I think
the only thing we should be apologizing
for us their blatant priorities and
prioritization of profits over human
rights I agree what an embarrassment
I agree bado I agree all we give this
we've recognized that the views
expressed by Houston Rockets general
manager Daryl Morey
have deeply offended
any of our friends and fans in China
which is regrettable while deal has made
it clear that his tweet does not
represent the Rockets or an NBA the
values of the league support individuals
educating themselves and sharing their
views on matters important to them we
have great respect for the history and
culture of China and hope the Sports NBA
can be used as a unifying force I I
would I'm all Dorothy yeah I'm all for
the boycott of China in that way no me
too man until they until they mean they
just get away with whatever they want
the way they treat their own citizens I
think is you know I am it's just crazy
it's just crazy to me and it's way it's
what's wrong with a lot of things that
the ESPN and these major networks in
these big ballers these movers are just
like we don't touch it yeah well [ __ ]
China man
yeah but they make a bunch of my stuff
and 30% of the NBA how much money do you
guys need right we'll be fine without
China right yeah it's a NASA market but
I think that they they buy again I think
they behaves in a very it's antithetical
to American values and probably human
right in many ways but now but now I can
care now I need any stance NBA player
tastes um you're out oh no you don't get
you don't get a vote anymore yeah LeBron
your opinion doesn't count it doesn't
get any more that's right it doesn't
count because when the window [ __ ] hit
the fan who were you you know what you
don't want to affect your bottom dollar
so you're not really making a difference
right you don't really care it's crazy I
know it's a bummer what else you got
it's just a fun gender-reveal fail I'm
sure you guys have seen this right it's
gonna go way up but I'll just clear it
with
[Music]
and this part we floss no kids probably
sees me I gotta kiss he I fell hard on I
did dad's not very athletic yeah though
those gender-reveal party this I mean
you know we did we did we had a cupcake
we didn't know what color was inside we
have them tell us we oh yeah I'm just
hoping that oh wow it's blue all right
you saw the couple that [ __ ] yeah
they did like a burnout in the car they
did the smoke supposed to be a certain
color like pink or blue and I think he
crashed and died start a fire so yeah
right sounds like a huge fire [ __ ] or
how about the dude who's goes to shoot
the arrow in the foot in the woods and
that's what started a huge mass higher
north California yeah Jesus Christ he's
like set to pay back like millions of
dollars was it Arizona yeah yeah million
I got a girl man 47 thousand acres burn
in Arizona because these dumbasses she's
I don't [ __ ] look there you go hey
cool man
you sent all of you Arizona on fire now
guys you got to pay attention to that
stuff an off-duty Border Patrol agent
through the party well dude so called
gender reveal party is meant to announce
the baby's gender yes we thought they
are all right guys dinky set up a target
with the words boy and girl it meant to
burst in a pink or blue the target ain't
a highly explosive substance called
tannery here I didn't know yeah but also
look at the feel you dude
you should know it's so bad yeah you
gotta know that look at the right look
at that oh my lord
yeah how stupid do you have to be a
psychic come the world not good dog I
know dude hey you think about that well
you uh you're a boy and your boy was 47
that let's that's not a good home yeah
it's still working to this day yeah to
pay off yeah I mean I could cost you
some money gender-reveal burnout starts
a vehicle fire yeah I think that's one
of the ones that we're talking about oh
my god yeah but but also just oh cool
it's a boy a girl man celebrate amongst
yourselves what is this [ __ ] they're
doing for the gram aren't they like oh
it's a boy it's so cool then what just
[Music]
so his car catches on and that's a
really big fire to let that smoke hits
you quick that's ah dude what's some
dump ship some Thai people so stupid the
guy with the you like dude there's
literally tinder if you if I was a KB
for my baby come November I need you to
set up a gender-reveal party came here
and if you immediately know but I won't
immediately I go it ran and I got this
isn't Brandon why I would never get the
wrong number never get the [ __ ] out of
my face we're all too busy for any of
this and also it doesn't matter but also
but if I called you like I'm like what
do you got me here's my idea we're gonna
go to a real drive field and then what I
have where you go you know all the fires
going on yeah don't worry about it so
we're gonna do a dry field and I'm gonna
have this I'm have this explosive device
and it's a boy or girl and when you
shoot it it's gonna explode fire
everywhere and then we'll find out it's
poor girl I'm like no but we'll do it in
that field of dry grass we're gonna do
rich dried white there's nothing but you
don't buy where all those fires right
yeah let's do it over there in the day
yeah in acres and acres of dry grass
make sure there's absolutely no water
around yeah
how crazy is that in Arizona God man
that's amazing
your dummy that kids probably not
dealing with he's not gonna get all the
brains if he inherits him from what
kidding I get bullied in school yeah
dumb dumb parents sometimes are
extraordinary kids though some people
piles have dumb kids
so we'll see we're gonna give birth to a
pyro or that kids name is zerah killer
not a pyromaniac like this is God
showing like I'm telling you man I
burned 47 thousand acres to you guys a
heads up yep yet the next Hitler coming
god damn what else you get higher this
is on BBC news so you would imagine if
you saw a plane that crashed into a ski
lift flat and hung they both survived
with like pretty much no injuries
what well out they were all one guy fell
out I think the pilot fell out and he
was fine but the other guy got stuck in
there so they had to get emergency crews
that's [ __ ] nuts actually the look at
the video no this is a rescue team oh
and that's the guy waiting to get
rescued
oh he's just casual for my liking how
crazy is that it actually crashed into
that thing well those pilots got to be a
[ __ ] I'm so weird yeah I don't know
how they happens there's a bunch of
people killed in the cable car when a
jet fighter I'm still I'm surprised cut
okay with it yeah yeah I'm surprised
more people are killed on those uh on
the ski lifts
they're so dangerous you just hang in it
yeah well you're scary that is so crazy
yeah and that's in Italy all right
there's a very sad one here but I don't
think you guys even know who this person
is Sully this is a kpop star she killed
herself
yeah and it's so deep oh no she should
probably hung herself or something why I
don't there's no details on how she
killed herself but they said it's she
left a note and it doesn't there's no
like foul play poor thing but she so I
followed her career forever a beautiful
place to work in
the you know okay with kpop yeah so I
remember when she first started her
group she did a group called FX and they
were super popular you know she's still
like she was still famous until the day
she dies she does a deal
yeah she like six
something six million followers on this
one house she's just depressed like and
so she since the since the beginning she
was huge and doing great and then
finally the cyber bullies people
commenting and stuff it started to get
to her got that got to her this bad do
it in Korea you see how crazy it is how
all these huge stars in Korea they
they're all end up killing themselves
yeah because of social media it's so bad
that is very very high anyway it's in
Korea itself yeah it's one of the
highest is that where Apple makes their
[ __ ] but suicide so suicide in South
Korea first of all especially around
test taking time so they they have
ushered the pants but they did so much
pressure Koreans are so hard for there's
a lot of suicide but last exert ladies
is al is there a lot of hate out it was
a young kids and hate non-celebrity
especially the celebrities off why why
are creams like that I think it's just
fan culture right within kpoppers know
it's so much worry turn the the losers
here's now and unified so in Korea what
it is is its unified so in Korea like
there are very organized fan clubs of
someone like this girl right and they
they'll wear the same colors they'll all
go to the same concert they late that
it's all like to uniform so right so in
this kind of case there was a story
about how one k-pop group one of the
girls was behaving in a way that was
considered contrary to Korean values I
was in there well yeah because they're
very conservative yeah and literally
they they wouldn't cheer for they'd like
when it was her turn they did this big
fellow like yeah and they all went they
want that bad section went dead quiet so
they they they they'll hit you in an
organized massive torpedo blitz and it's
[ __ ] crazy why not just get off
social media field inside peace with all
those she's she's been like she even
fought against cyber bullying so she was
like a you know would he call that like
a spokesperson ambassador for people
that you know get cyber bully she's like
the first lady she was okay yeah well
you know yeah and she was even on
television shows where that had other
celebrities and they talked about
comments how they get to you
and eventually I
all her when she was like Brian you know
hey bright-eyed and bushy-tailed all the
way in so she started getting like
skinnier withering away got really
really dark and then eventually boned
this happened like yesterday Hawkman
because the [ __ ] Twitter also hey
pops you have you read some about the
schools like how they god it's like a
factor it's like a factor they drop some
beats though well you know it's you know
you know like I want that well [ __ ] you
man you got hard on the kids just this
podcast only kid honey booboo everybody
meets dude they drop beats but they come
up some yeah contract then why'd you say
drop beats what does that mean what do
you got you know look it's you know like
you guys are know that South Korea has
like the fastest fastest internet speeds
around you know in the world right yes
fan on top around no it's true
no I know yeah and there you know
broadband their cell phone whatever if I
coverage is crazy like that over there
too so they have all these different
platforms where they build all these
social networking sites so social
networking is huge in Asia especially in
South Korea out there than here yeah so
there's a bunch of them and then I'm
guessing she's gonna see way more stuff
than you guys would even sit down here
why can't she just have someone runs a
huge star so you she's walking into like
a store she'll see articles she'll see
like people you know all the sorts of
stuff she got super skinnier that poor
super skinny super skinny and then
finally she apparently you know
committed suicide but we don't have him
there's no girl
Wow there should be a nobody there well
she's missing his band in the world
yeah and even America's kpop right now
is that her right there yeah is this her
song yeah but we can't play might have
been [ __ ] up and she's not here
tonight is here for myself hmm she was
in movies she's uh in dramas and she was
a child actor then got into kpop is this
very track I don't know if this is your
anymore
do were you ever alone with her chin
what
but this is later on so this one she got
the demons yeah that's such a shame
who would it be like over here
committing suicide she probably had some
issues man
well she was enormous when they first
came out but she's still super famous
until she died but uh who's someone
that's there's only in a band
yeah like Camilla like she oh she's been
me yeah but I would say just harmony big
no was that example the ladies too big
you say it so who's hot and then went
out their own Bush it was on her own
muffin she wanted to leave the group
there's just two more famous Kelly
Rowland ah she's way beyond cake how
does a stupid no no it'd be like what
about like Nick Carter like you know
probably Nick Carter ish hardly 25 years
old oh wow yes you're alive man over man
that's a [ __ ] shame well you weren't
Korean such haters man I think it's just
a pure numbers you know talking about
the internet speeds on the surface it
matters all those different platforms
the more how many people are in Korea
uh-huh population of Korea and compared
to United States so I feel like the
United States cuz don't wait more losers
we have more losers Korea much kpop has
such a large as everyone just Korean 51
just South Korea and kpop is also it's
it's Asia like everyone Eva causing
billions of people and Asia does have
once again all that coverage and also
higher in it's a bigger deal over there
it's just more platforms to talk smack
and react South Korea exports all their
pop culture to everywhere yes yes are we
headed that way though don't you think
if South Korea's doing that one America
names a structure though yeah we don't
have them for sure they built their so
they built their infrastructure remember
when the internet was coming to be so
they were able to put in cables and all
the optics and but we have with five
Gina I think it's available but no one
really gets it yeah where our
infrastructure is so [ __ ] emo or
infrastructure in Venice
it goes back to the 50s I mean dealing
with Kate wire wires
oh yeah some of them you know
go jogging in the fields whatever you
lose signal that doesn't happen in Korea
like you can go big time out of nowhere
and also you know that underground town
always can see them with your eyes what
with eyes you what with my eyes you know
when you go running in there other guys
running know where you meet where the
guy well yeah you ever see that in
Griffith Park the gay section where guys
parked their Miatas or whatever there's
a section where your charm man the
really positions where the men hang out
yeah and they just go for walk it's a
slub right it's recharge your Tesla's
well charge and suck well charge suck
dan that's guy I didn't know Korea was
that dark I mean I think it's a sheer
numbers I mean cuz honestly if you guys
see hateful comments right let's say
your your audience base is like tripled
so you get more hateful comments you're
gonna just notice the amount of hateful
comments but why weren't they'd like do
a class for these kpop kids on social
media now no they're actually trying to
do stuff like that especially after her
death they'd have their pressing hard on
it yeah but I mean yeah for Korean pop
stars a lot of them are super huge
Ryan's car they're super love right
they're rich they're famous I was so
zoned out of I find the Korea the kpop
stuff fascinating man they're rich
they're famous good-looking all stuff
but but I have no that's enough to work
for him you know they can't do anything
like warm no matter money your honor
they're you know they're it's like
you're working I mean once you get to
that what her level she could do
whatever she wants really yeah she can't
be anybody openly no that's why she left
the group she left the I think the
agency to as far as I know like they're
her actual because the kpop dance on
Vice okay documentary baked like they
can't say they have boyfriends
girlfriends that is who they date they
can't go out after concerts there's no
drugs there's no alcohol Radiolab die
think it was them they did a thing about
how this they had naked pictures of this
one gal who was a kpop star and when the
ex-boyfriend tried to sell them to
various that was an actress and there
was like a producer she hooked up with
that they were dating and
but it's showing this video somewhere in
case we can hear the guy at the editor
it was like [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah not buying this like in Korean like
a revolted yeah and it was like while
and then there is the fans shutdown then
one news Camaro will pave oh wow
favorite one newspaper bottom and Korea
as a nation basically said we're not
buying it okay yeah gangster this was
what we should do and we should we don't
though I don't think it's happening we
get them a job because we don't really
care about violating this is in Japan
other kpop this is in Japan but this is
a J pop star yeah so this crazy guy
right here is a super fan of this girl
he was able to pinpoint her location by
looking through her social media posts
through her eyes the reflections in our
eyes look the same okay all whether
you're gonna lie they all have that like
it's a touch of the started right you
don't talk about say no promote roles
have that same vibe good for that I
dunno what you're talking about though
yeah you know excited a certain look
found out where she was yeah so you
found out her we're sure her building
was Larissa's estimated the floor she
lives on based on her windows and the
angle the sunlight hitting her eyes
smart dude that's just rolls off smart
dude you can see some reflection there
right can you zoom in but I mean this
guy must holy [ __ ] God Jeep yet to go
head what it up happening to get a hold
of her found her at her actual door and
then put some sort of towel around her
mouth and then groped her so he's
arrested now but that was I think that
was the extent of it she looks like it
all looks like a living doll oh she had
deafness surgery on erisa it looks like
it yeah yeah come on chin I don't know
that's her group are they called the
Chumley's they called the the are they
called the ten-year-old girls they all
have that look there's a young why is
that a sign so agent why is this let's
do it today that's it like yeah I have
to do that you want to take pictures you
do it I do it all the time now I'll do
it oh there's a new one though agents do
that that's another one part it looks
like a heart isn't it cute it's it's
almost like doing this but now so if I
start doing this will
no oh you should do it tried tonight
I'll get it if you look like I'm holding
something but it starts me saying I love
you I want to do why just do this let me
do this
hey do you do this that means I want to
do this honk-honk
yeah hold your junk so this guy end up
put a towel over mouth and just feel up
on her titty yeah I'm pretty sure you
probably would've done more if I got
scared she got away she got away
hmm oh well it's a sustained facial
injuries I required one week to heal I
was a slapped around a little bit I just
I'm just picturing and did you just
can't say it casually under your breath
like that you can't do that because it's
so sick so desperate it does enough to
study hours of her incredible approach
but a down covering her mouth with the
towels Rach I guess he was either maybe
there's something in the towel to you
know no ha yeah or not they said he was
unemployed - oh [ __ ] that's a depressed
that's a that's a desperate human being
it's all here oh they both well I don't
know what to say about any of that
yeah me neither but of course don't ever
say it's a facial injuries
groped her that it yeah that's it I
guess Brian hey let me slap you around
no cover me cover my mouth with a towel
ah Billy you thought the movie did it to
a lot of guys I I only the towel just
carry with my palm you got big palms but
I do yeah cover your stupid mouth don't
call it stupid on us don't say that and
I would fight back yeah if I back yeah
and one thing you need to know and I
want to sign off this way I'm be a
prayer October 24 25 26
you'll be it helium this weekend at
human Philadelphia this Thursday Friday
Saturday past the ice house I'm at the
ice house next Thursday I'm when I'm
Robin friends sha'ban friends at the ice
house and then on the 27th me and Shaab
and some very special guests at the
Comedy Store
that's a Sunday on the 28th and then in
November Dallas Dallas don't think I've
ever played death if I have I forget and
should be slapped around I'm in Dallas
November 14th through the 16th Salt Lake
City wise guys yeah use a wise guy for
his clubs wise guys in Salt Lake City
November 21st through the 23rd Kansas
City December 6 through the 7th and then
just announced Atlantic City New Jersey
that is December 14th and then Oklahoma
City December 27th get your tickets now
tvk calm what's up dude relax hey I'll
play cuz you know that I know you have a
good time there I see another yep have a
good time Atlantic City but I'm gonna
stick around watch the fights with the
fans out there that's what you should do
now that I can't think of anything more
Brendan you're gonna have a blast
that's gonna be great enjoy that enjoy
bastard see you this weekend listen II
got it dude don't slap my mouth I got
tricks up my sleeve alright rink how
come I come out I'll honk your dong but
the man dragon will make it will be
making cinders dragon makin cinders you
WIP cuz a suck your 24 25 26 brand prop
get your [ __ ] ten
see that gaydar town that's the fun kid
rap